your hard-earned money isn't going as
far as it used to the biggest price
bikes were at the pump up more than 30
percent beef nearly 17 percent more
expensive inflation on fridges and
freezers more than 15 percent costs
associated with owning a home up 14
percent new home prices climbed more
than 13 percent non-electrified kitchen
items and tableware rose more than 10
percent and the price of fresh milk rose
nearly 6 percent reflecting higher
prices paid to farmers set by the
federal government but all of that is
looking in the rearview mirror at what
already happened but some economists are
warning of 80s style inflation in the
coming months spring and summer is going
to have even higher inflation passing
six percent
is an absolute
certainty
perhaps even pushing towards the seven
percent mark move over kovid the crisis
in ukraine is now the top wild card when
it comes to inflation russia is one of
the world's biggest energy exporters
ukraine and russia together export a
quarter of all wheat and are major
producers of corn potatoes and barley
factor in tough sanctions on russia and
countries like egypt which depends on
both countries for wheat could see
widespread food shortages
the region's also a key producer of
minerals used in cars and tech devices
add that to existing supply chain
challenges and you have a recipe for
much higher prices even more shortages
all of this will hit less developed
countries hardest and here at home
vulnerable households they're also
getting squeezed by gas prices and are
getting squeezed by rent increases all
of those they're going to have to make
some harder choices
to offset the loss of purchasing power
many will cut back where they can but
growing your investments is another
tactic according to this wealth manager
there are many good quality companies
that are trading very cheaply and we're
even calling them stupid cheap at this
point in that they they keep increasing
earnings
every little bit helps to blunt the
erosion of your purchasing power ann
gaviola global news toronto